a russians are paying a price for the
invasion of ukraine basic goods are
becoming more expensive as the value of
the ruble falls and economic sanctions
start to bite but could the rest of the
world be affected as well this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm nick
clark so russia's invasion of ukraine
has triggered some of the most severe
sanctions ever from the west they're
designed to hurt russia's economy and
deprive president vladimir putin of
money to pay for the war the currency
the ruble has fallen by a third against
the u.s dollar some russian banks have
been banned from the swift messaging
system used for international
transactions
the united states the european union and
their allies are blocking access to much
of the country's 640 billion dollars in
foreign cash reserves russia's central
bank is trying to limit the fallout by
raising interest rates to 20
the kremlin insists the country will
ride out the pain but the fear has
caused a run on the banks
since thursday everyone has been running
between atms to redraw cash someone gets
lucky others not so lucky
[Music]
it's not clear how we will be buying
groceries and other stuff if swift is
turned off all foreign goods are paid
for by card how will we purchase them i
work in a department store how will it
buy clothes from italy i wonder i don't
know how other areas will be affected
everything is working in russia but
there could be some shortages
it won't affect me at all because i'm
not too rich i'm an average earner it
will affect our country i think but we
will overcome it all
well of course the sanctions could have
an impact outside of russia as well the
world's 11th biggest economy is a major
exporter of fuel and food the war could
push up prices globally let's take a
closer look
well russia produces 10 percent of the
world's oil as the west warned of a a
russian invasion back in november prices
were nearly 85 a barrel now they are
more than 100 a barrel and rising
moscow supplies 40 percent of europe's
natural gas prices on the continent have
increased by a third since thursday when
the invasion began
russia is the world's largest wheat
exporter prices last year were already
31 percent higher than in 2020 that's
according to the un's food and
agriculture agency economists fear they
could climb even higher
all right let's bring in our guests in
moscow we have pavel felgenhauer as a
defensive military analyst in shanghai
and china dan wang a chief economist at
the hang seng bank china and in london
jeevan sander who is an economist at
king's college london welcome all of you
to the program
first up i just want to focus on the
situation within russia for now we'll
look at the global situation uh in a few
minutes but pavel pavel felgenha
vladimir putin says he's indifferent
to sanctions is that true do you think
well russia was preparing
obviously that there can be further
sanctions actually russia has been under
sanctions for already eight years since
uh
14
and more were coming and so there were
reserves made of different things
of
chips and components to make planes and
other materials and of course russia
with the price of oil being high in the
price of natural gas too
made large hard currency reserves and it
was believed that russia could wither
the storm the sanctions would have some
effect further on but not immediate it
turned out differently uh the west uh
uh agreed very promptly to freeze the
assets of the central bank and that was
a shock and awe event right so what does
what are the implications of that
because those hard currency reserves you
talked about being pretty much half
doesn't they say he loses
access to much of the 640 billion
dollars that was there
what's going to be the
only that belongs to the central bank as
reserve it's also the sovereign fund
which is under the custodianship of the
central bank so and that's also incred
foreign currency
so that means the central bank does not
have the capability to support the rubo
by using those reserves they have been
frozen and actually there's reports that
not only in euros dollars
sterling and apparently yen actually
switzerland the neutral country
apparently is also looking into freezing
russian assets so it would be the frank
too that's not that's not good at all so
today moscow there was panic in the city
the pro the
rubo was in free fall the central bank
moved in and somewhat managed to
stabilize the situation okay we'll come
into the situation within moscow in just
just a second pavel sorry to interrupt
but i just want to move it on we'll come
back to you in a second about what's
happening on the streets uh dan dan wang
outside of china have you been surprised
by the the level of sanctions finally
being imposed now on russia
i'm actually not that surprised uh
gathering all the political signals in
the market from europe and the u.s it
just seems it will happen that way uh
the swift is used and the my line of
business is considered as a nuclear
option in the financial world
but energy products are still in
exemption so i just don't think the pain
would be big enough to deter russia yet
there has to be more of a
consistent behavior and alliance between
western countries in order to cause the
real damage they want to see juventus
what do you think do you think there
needs to be
more effort to to up the the level of
sanctioning going on
actually these sanctions are clear
punitive and overwhelming we should be
clear that as of this morning the
russian economy is in crisis the ruble
is crashing inflation with increased
bank runs we are also seeing russia is
fundamentally much poorer this morning
than it was
yesterday these sectors will have a huge
and damaging effect and one of the
ironies of course of this is because
putin spent since 2014 insulating the
russian economy from his western
neighbors by selling very little debt
abroad by restricting
imports by trying to build that reserve
it also means these sanctions are going
to have relatively less effect on
western economies putin gambled
everything on this card of invading
ukraine he thought he had a war chest
ready it's clear that is no longer the
case he went all in and it looks like
he's about to lose very badly right so
pavel the ruble as you were just saying
the ruble has bombed
let's hone in now on the impacts that
that is going to have on the lives of
the men and women on the street what
will it do to the cost of living for the
145 million people in russia
well as a central bank right now today
stepped in they managed to stabilize the
situation there was even a rebounds of
the ruble
but the
medicine is very very bitter they have
risen the their basic lending rate from
nine and a half percent to twenty twenty
percent means that there's the russian
uh
uh industry is going to tank normal
industry can't work at such a uh a rate
only i don't know speculative trading in
the black market can
that means there's going to be a
recession in russia there's going to be
a severe economic recession and that's
going to hate the population very
seriously there's going to be shortages
because there's going to be a problem
with imports and not only because of
money because russia is still selling
oil and getting some money
but
that is not frozen
but there's logistical problems
logistical companies are refusing to
bring containers to russia and we won't
having bananas but we're also not having
i say pre-coursers to make uh generic uh
medicines and everything is going to go
and that's going to be there's this all
of it in some is going to affect very
badly the internal political situation
there's going to be serious discontent
in the coming months and that will
coupled with a war that seems not very
popular and not very successful right i
was going to come onto that what do you
think what sense are you getting from
people the people you know the people
you chat to in the shops and so forth
about what's going on and what's
happened as a result of these sanctions
ultimately as a result of
vladimir putin's decision to invade well
i mean right now people are in shock
because their gadgets are not working
this is not working so people are trying
to get something buy something
do something or just simply are sitting
and uh
in
frustration because they don't their
wives are kind of crumbling about them
moscowites were traveling a lot abroad
now there are also no russian planes
around there anywhere the russian
foreign minister couldn't go to geneva
and another people of ordinary people
also can't go anywhere so this is a kind
of very serious frustration
uh there is some anti-war movement it's
not yet very big but it is there and
that's also eating into the
eternal political stability if these
things right now it's not yet a
political problem for the kremlin but it
can soon become
every because all these things will be
adding up right and people are of course
frustrated asking me questions what
comes next and i don't have any good
news for them it could be much worse
jeevan sander in london to what extent
can can russia fight back because we've
heard in the last few hours of russia
closing its airspace for 36 odd
countries um yeah that's going to have
repercussions across the world isn't it
it will do the real damaging weapon that
russia has of course is as you've
mentioned a huge amount of energy
exports the second largest producer of
natural gas here in london 40 of our
electricity comes from energy without
much of the gas in the european union as
well does come from russia but whilst it
can try to restrict those exports we
should remember that russia also needs
to export that in order to have dollars
come into the country and not see the
ruble crash further it needs those
dollars russia's economic sanctions back
to the to the western world if you like
outside of energy and wheat are very
limited and even with energy and wheat
it's very difficult to see how
effectively they could deploy it given
how badly they need at this point in
time us dollars it doesn't look like the
russian economy or russian government
here has a huge amount of maneuver by
which to strike back at western nations
yes indeed just as we emerge from the
the pandemic crisis we we walk straight
into this kind of storm cloud of war
don't we
dan and wang in shanghai uh with your uh
financial hat on if you like how far
reaching do you think
the consequences of russia's invasion of
ukraine
will be for the world and
indeed for us all wherever we may live
well i think for con for a country like
ukraine its economy probably will have
to be put back by at least five years
just due to this war but for the rest of
the world unfortunately i think the
economic impact will be quite drastic in
the beginning but quickly fade off right
now we see a lot of adjustment in the
stock market and people are rushing to
the safe assets but judging by
historical experience say the period
after the gulf war or period after 9 11
the markets will return to normal
usually between one to one to six months
and right now we see actually many
countries see more opportunities to
strengthen their bond with russia
including china so it's not the case for
like iran or cuba that they're very
isolated from the rest of the world
russia still has friends and allies from
other parts of the world but if you know
we've been talking about wheat supply
russia is the biggest supplier of wheat
in the world if that has is hit badly
you know it's going to affect basic the
basic commodity of bread isn't it and
that is going to have repercussions
around the world it's not something
that's just going to
you know evaporate once the invasion
stops or they come to some sort of
agreement if they do and this this might
drag on for for months
well food security is certainly a prime
concern but the impact again is quite
uneven
for countries in middle east and north
africa they depend more heavily on
russian and ukraine supply especially in
wheat and rip seeds
so
we will see some disproportionate
impact for the poor people in those
countries if you look at countries like
turkey the inflation pressure is already
very high
and i just can see that more people
would have to suffer from high living
costs in the months to come
stephen what do you think what do you
have how do you think the sanctions on
russia will reverberate across the world
global economy really for the for them
for the man and woman on the street from
you know from kenya to london
so yeah it's certainly true to whatever
extent people are exposed to russian
financial assets we are going to see
some kind of repercussion we've seen
stock markets down slightly this morning
similarly the same is true if russia
decides to offload its dollars
denominator debt for example but the
more severe question is really about to
what extent energy prices as well as
food prices are affected that's what
matters for people on the street now we
had a threat from medvedev a few days
ago so that he would cause the price of
gas to increase by more than double in
the uk that would mean another increase
of energy prices of about a thousand
pounds for the average family another
three points on inflation at the same
time we're seeing across the oecd
certainly inflation spiking and living
standards fall inside the uk we've seen
the biggest fall or we'll see this year
for working households the biggest fall
in after tax income for 30 years we're
seeing those pressures of course
everywhere so the real question here is
what happens to those energy exports and
what happens to those food exports
pavel what do you think that threat from
medvedev to put a squeeze on on gas flow
and and
push up the price is that something that
you will see come into play uh well
actually i don't know
today their president putin and kram one
had a meeting on these on sanctions and
russian response
the results are not yet known
this is maybe a possibility
but again of course
that is a dangerous weapon because if
russia begins to squeeze gas supplies uh
the west will begin to squeeze gas from
and
that a gas problem has assets in the
west even has natural gas in western
europe and in central europe and
underground
facilities
which could be confiscated i don't know
there's a the
cutting off supply of oil and gas uh was
a very dangerous weapon
there's going to be a lot of
consideration before using that of
course the first reaction by president
putin was actually to threaten uh
brandish the new queer
weapon
and he announced the kind of uh high
that the level of readiness i mean the
equivalent of the american def con has
been
lifted
and so basically russia is saying if you
impose sanctions and last week and maybe
begin to use nukes
actually it's possible that a nuclear
weapon could be exploded somewhere in a
safe uh
in a place like an over the seas an
empty sea somewhere
in the north sea in the the norwegian
sea or the atlantic
where it won't cause any harm as a
demonstration of russian determination
because such things have been kind of
proposed and
tested without explosion of course in
russian military exercises beginning
from the 90s it's called
de-escalation through nuclear escalation
a demonstrative nuclear attack that
sounds like a risky game to me
and that's a possibility right now we
should not consider that and how that
will have a reaction on world markets
indeed
dan wang
well let me ask you about that what do
you make of that first of all
i think it's an incredible threat of
course the military power is
quite obvious for russia
but the real question is what does
russia want out of this war with ukraine
and the economic sanctions pretty much
is anticipated before it started this
war and
the bottom line is
the power that western countries exert
on russia can also be the western
country's vulnerability
um for europe to cut off its energy ties
with russia it cannot be very long it
has to be a temporary solution because
europe really depend on russia for the
energy supply and for the u.s it can
certainly kick out russia from the
swiftest system but that means a
weakening position for dollar
denominated a global order
so now it just leaves all all countries
in this tricky balance and i don't think
russia will necessarily lose in this
battle and in this negotiation
eventually maybe
the trade relations between russia and
china will get closer and probably will
get more political power from europe as
well and dan how do you think china fits
into this this tricky balance as you
describe it because earlier this month
putin held talks with xi jinping
where the two leaders declared this sort
of unending friendship with no limits
and no forbidden areas of cooperation
do you think that's strained now
well russia is part of the belt and road
initiative countries and there are
already a lot of collaboration on the
ground
infrastructure in technology e-commerce
things like that there's even the
currency swap system
and in times like this a
friendlier face in china would be a
great support for russia and already we
have seen more talks on uh on the ground
between different trade representatives
um on uh from china and from russia so
it is more opportunities for china to
gain in this situation and for russia as
well maybe to pursue a different path
for its future growth all right steven
uh london is is well known for it said
links to russian money isn't it uh what
about the mass ranks of oligarchs
will they always have putin's back we've
seen roman abramovic she's stepped back
from the ownership of chelsea football
club couple of others beginning to to
speak out against war
what do you think that might represent
it certainly looks like oligarchs their
own kind of interest may no longer align
with putin we know for example the
british government is looking at seizing
putin linked oligarch property in london
i've just seen the french are
considering similar actions so certainly
oligarchs may start to think about kind
of diverging from putin i suppose on the
other side though we've also seen danger
from those oligarchs who do decide to
leave putin and fundamentally what will
determine his survival is whether or not
he still has the backing of the security
and the armed forces we should remember
dictators like maduro can survive in
office if they have make sure they have
you know the support of the men with
guns so fundamentally for putin whilst
the oligarchs may leave him or more of
them they think about it what it's
really about is what is his position and
support within his own armed forces
pavel felgenhauer what's your assessment
of vladimir putin's position uh in the
coming months given that we're beginning
to hear uh you know from the oligarchs
suggesting that perhaps that this war
was ill-advised
is that something that may grow in
virgin and add to that unrest on the
streets that you were talking about a
little bit earlier
well there is of course it will be
unrest there will be economic
frustration of large parts of the
russian population but that's of course
not enough at all to kind of bring any
kind of substantial change in regime or
substantially change russian political
objectives the kremlin political
objectives what should be added that it
should be uh widespread discontent
within the security operators yes the
military and actually the civilian
bureaucracy which is so also very
important in russia that's how things
begin to change in russia if when such
changes happen
let's say this war is not very popular
and it's not apparently very popular
with the russian military too there were
dissenting voices and signals coming
from there that this is the wrong thing
to do
and it doesn't seem that maybe in some
instances the russian military are not
fighting to full capacity or at least
maybe holding back maybe under orders or
maybe that they don't want to fight this
war very much uh so it's a complicated
situation the umbrella the putin's
regime may begin to
wobble in the coming months
will there be any change or not again
that's anybody's question before it
begins to happen it's very hard to
predict but the security the military
have to at least look the other way if
there's a popular discontent can begin
to change anything in russia okay uh
jamin i'd like to end with you if i may
if hostilities were to end and some
agreement was reached how quickly could
things economically
in russia around the world get back on
track or is this you know set in train a
long-term potential recession
well i mean i think russia at this point
will face some kind of recession at
least in the short term
if it is the case that relations were to
go back to normal you'd think they'd be
able to in some sense recover but also
let's think about what the long-term
implications would still be europe would
very much be looking to decouple their
natural gas from russia and putin in any
case that would be you think now more of
a push to net zero there will be a
complete change in relationships
especially while putin is still the
leader in russia and more broadly it's
very difficult to see a situation in
which our dealings with russia will be
normalized while vladimir putin is still
leader we can't go back to where we were
10 days ago
interesting
uh thank you all for joining us we've
run out of time do you appreciate your
all your perspectives on this very
important story uh pebble falcon
dan wang and jeevan sander thanks very
much indeed and thank you for watching
you can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion you can go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and you
can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me nick clark and the whole whole
team here at al jazeera it's goodbye
you